they don't have cross eyes back Japanese
Korean parenting what do you think are
the differences what were your parents
like you know what's crazy I mean I grew
up with a lot of Koreans and going to
their house and just seeing how
everything operates I think we're the
closest from all the other Asians like
you know it's just the way that it's
it's kind of like a dictatorship you
know and especially if like your parents
are just got anger problems and they're
just always yelling for no reason and I
don't know it's it's weird but I think I
see it in the Korean home too it's
really similar I mean the things that
you would your life is constantly
threatened like in Korean to say you
know if I translate it it would be this
is what you would hear clean your room
or you're gonna die you're like six you
know I'm gonna kill you and throw you
away like that's the kind of language
the Asian Korean parents used you know
my dad was so [ __ ] scary there yah
yah yah right and he would just he would
take it I remember one thing we were
eating and he [ __ ] flipped the
[ __ ] food all the food hit the
ceiling right and he chased everyone
through the home and he caught everyone
and like you [ __ ] beat to share them
yeah no no that's why God gave him a
stroke too much too far I love you
speedy recovered you yeah I understand
that feeling though sometimes cuz I told
my dad I was like you keep beating me
just wait till I become the same size as
you I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
and even harder I was about 11 or 10
when you talk bad yeah ya know cuz I
mean at that age you're growing right
and you're like just a couple more years
just watchful just watched what my
brother did you ever square up - no cuz
he ran away when I was 14 so at that
time it was like well your dad ran away
I don't yeah I don't I don't I can't get
revenge your dad left you guys yeah so I
never had the revenge that I wanted and
so you don't have a relationship with
your dad now
no he's somewhere in West LA or
something people told me wait he's here
but he's in LA he's he's somewhere oh my
god what's his name I can't say okay I
don't want people to find him so he just
took off basically left right stop it
he's nuts up he's Japanese okay mister
this isn't he's Japanese yes he lives in
West LA okay any vaguely looks like you
but older yeah okay I'm gonna find them
okay
Japanese 50 is big you're gonna start
talking hey you know Joe what what's
your last name sir
right oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] liar
he left them yeah
he who else do you have brothers and
sisters I have an older brother yeah oh
my god that must been so painful yeah he
left or was it a relief for you for what
I mean like you said my brother yeah it
was it made my relationship with my mom
stronger so when people go all he left
it was like well it's actually better
cuz there was no more violence and then
me and my mom started bonding better we
you know we did what we had to do like
make ends meet and through that struggle
I think it got really you know tell my
friends who are going through either a
divorce or are like contemplating it but
they say no we have to stay together cuz
of the kids and I'm like that's not
healthy for children to see toxic
relationships or abusive relationships
either it's better that you part ways
and they live in two healthy households
versus or one healthy household versus
you know a family that stays together
that's just [ __ ] you know a hundred
percent
he's very emotionally all over the pan
just said it was better for all I know
but it just makes me so angry let me ask
you this you don't ever want to see him
um no not really maybe but I I made it I
made closure how how would when I think
it took many many years because there
was a lot of resentment and a lot of
these feeling
of like man I wish I had a like I would
see other people's dads yeah and I'd be
like man your dad takes care of your
your dad loves you he sits you down he
talks to you he gives you life advice
all that stuff I didn't have that I had
to learn a lot on my own but I started
creating father figures from my friend's
dad like right here cool right and Bobby
yeah right here I look I'm your dad
really yeah I be honest with you I
raised you bro yeah what if it was you
would know you don't really young yeah
yeah what I want to know is this how do
you have two sons raise them until
they're in 1380 teenage years and then
just leave and then not want to see them
again
my brother's 12 years older than me so
he was like oh yeah so how does that how
do you how do you do that as a human
being well going back to the closure
thing what I realized is that my dad
never really had a father either so he
was you know born to a really rich CEO
my grandpa that just popped him out and
then his mom died during giving
childbirth
oh so one time yeah and then he had like
ten brothers and sisters because you
know that time everyone had a bunch of
kids oh yeah yeah so my grandpa would
just have them being taken care of by
all these other people so he was just
being passed around Oersted like a
family unit either he doesn't so my mom
was explaining to me like you know we
should have sympathy for the guy because
he grew up really shitty so he did
better than his own situation and that's
all we got to look forward to yeah like
what if he started what do you feel like
half siblings or what if he's like
started another family which I would
that would be insane but I'm glad I'm
with a white girl because I'm not gonna
be [ __ ] my sister I don't I don't buy
what you just said man I'll tell you
another story gonna hear it what I just
buy that oh well you should have
sympathy because he didn't have a you
know the you know his upbringing
anything that right the man needs
closure that was out I know Bob
pick at it go ahead and there was a
there was a kid right his dad left him
when he was like what a kid right his
mom a southern mom raised him and he had
really just he was lost he smoked pot
this and that and um then he went to
college and then he went to Harvard you
know law school and he became the
president that says I mean you don't
mean I mean you could you could take his
story and go wow you know his dad wasn't
you know he wasn't around he was an
[ __ ] and then he went no I'm gonna be
there for my kids I am gonna be the
president of United States you know so I
don't buy that [ __ ] well I'm gonna be
nobody didn't your dad your dad right
had those circumstances oh and when I'm
not gonna be a man and I'm not gonna
[ __ ] fulfill my obligation plus how
do you not have a love for a kid this
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] dog right here
this Remi just listen to me right a
month and a half ago she said she's
gonna do which is gonna arm dog you know
do dog rescue yeah I'm like this piece
of [ __ ] right here I [ __ ] love this
dog now they like it's an extension of
myself you know why because I have a
heart you know and I they're you know
regardless of all the abuse that I felt
regardless of just all the broken
relationships and the sad things that
happened to Bobby Lee poor me right at
the end of the day I have love in my
heart I do I have when I see things on
TV that's sad I cry I can't you know
what if the [ __ ] are you doing right now
nothing he just he's giving me no no
what the [ __ ] are you doing right now
man I understand that right there's a
time and place bro I know he's having a
moment I was in a [ __ ] moment right
now dude and you [ __ ] it up towards
you got on George you
in the middle of the movie but today you
know what George today right we had in
the house right because we're doing this
thing for Theo von yeah we had Jordi an
exec one of the executives at Comedy
Central right we had a bunch of [ __ ]
people in the house right and I'm like
this guy George this guy George he's the
best he wants to do what you want to do
I've been telling you talking about you
the whole day and that's the kind of
[ __ ] you [ __ ] Paul dune [ __ ]
believe this
you saw it right oh my god I was in a
[ __ ] thing dude you got to check
yourself about the heart check your cell
all right on that note can we take a
break
[Music]